right now we have this fiber technique
not only in big cities like Munich or
Hamburg or Berlin but we have it right
here on the countryside in Oberhausen in
Bavaria ftth changed our profession we
did not have that possibility before and
as well as this technique with the
digital CT scans we are much quicker in
their operations and we can do much
safer operations because we have right
here a better planning then with a very
very slow x-ray technique
we could the removal of the first wisdom
tooth and also for this kind of
operation it is very important that we
have the perfect diagnostic of the
x-rays it is possible now for us to
transmit these x-rays because there's a
lot of data a big amount of data files
and in former times that has not been
possible in that quick way so this is a
digital CT scan of the head to change
something you see how quick it is that
is the big advantage now because the
machine is very expensive it costs one
hundred eighty thousand euros and in
this case if we would not be able to use
the brand new fiber technique in our
place here then we had to buy two
machines for the x-rays we have the
possibility to have the x-ray here and
with the fiber technique it's much
cheaper for us now because we can
develop the picture by internet to this
clinic that was the idea behind the
development of the fiber net in our
small community in former times it was
not possible to do that I am professor
in the Western China University and we
also can do now live surgery from our
operation room transmit that to the
University of Chengdu or any place in
China we are the first community in
Bavaria to give the idea also to the
government of Bavaria because we since
long time the community's expect that
they have a very very quick internet
connection as we are one of the first
communities we can give this input and
we also have some leader function now
for the government
in Bavaria our patients are very happy
due to the fiber technique now the
outlook for the future will be really to
use this quick response of the fiber by
the computers and then we are also with
much rigor with everything or anything
with attributes